[Music]
three years ago i was sitting at what i
thought to be the perfect job
i was making six figures working for a
tech company that provided free meals
unlimited vacation time off and yes it
did have a nap room
i thought i had reached the apex of the
american dream the american dream that
my parents immigrated from china and
vietnam to this country for
in hopes that their child would have a
chance at a better life than they did
but
it didn't feel that way
i read and watched the news every day
over 38 million americans are food
insecure
children are being forcibly separated
from their families at the border
texas school shooting florida school
shooting voting rights under attack
again
my friends and i would turn to each
other in frustration anger and sadness
did you see this
did you hear this
often
i cried
here i was living this picture-perfect
life but i knew back home in
philadelphia and across the country
people were struggling just to survive
in the neighborhood my parents first
immigrated to there are still people who
can't afford to keep a roof over their
heads
still people can't afford to put food on
the table
still children are getting asthma from
poor air quality just like i did
still in this country we call great
people are suffering and dying from
rooted injustices
the american dream rang hollow
so i quit my tech job
talking about these problems wasn't
going to make them go away
it wasn't enough to be frustrated angry
or disappointed everything i had that my
parents immigrated to this country for
meant little if there were people still
struggling like we once did
i decided to return home to philadelphia
to do the job i had done many years ago
as a student
community organizing
to me the most urgent problem our
country faced was that our democracy was
in crisis
so i joined a national organization
working to get out the vote
in that job i took a 60 pay cut and had
never been pushed to work harder in my
life
we were expected to work on holidays and
to quote sleep when we are dead
it was a far cry from the comfortable
silicon valley life i was living just a
few months ago
in that job i met and rediscovered
community organizers who have been doing
this work for decades in philadelphia
i first met tina marie two years ago
working to get out the vote in philly
the work we did was grueling but it was
made even more difficult by the pandemic
not everyone could vote in person
not everyone had internet access
and the people with power and resources
didn't seem to care
many times i wanted to bang my head
against a wall in frustration
but tina marie never gave up
she showed up to meetings she even used
her personal savings to help pay for her
neighbor's internet costs
tina marie is over 60 now
but she has the energy of a teenager for
over four decades she has been serving
her community
she spends her wednesdays attending
zoning board meetings which can go on
for six hours
she holds countless meetings for her
neighbors to hold developers accountable
demanding that they invest in home
ownership not just profit off of rent
tina marie does this work around the
clock
she works every day
into the evenings and on the weekends to
serve her community
and
she does this work for free
yes you heard that correctly
tina marie doesn't have a job that pays
her
serving her community is a full-time
role
why does she do it you may ask
because she says
if she doesn't do it
no one else will
her neighborhood
like many marginalized neighborhoods
across the country have faced the same
problems for decades lack of quality
housing education jobs
imagine
living paycheck to paycheck sending your
kids to schools with asbestos and being
surrounded by vacant lots overfilled
with trash
that's a reality that many americans in
this country still have to face today
and so you have people like tina marie
and tens of thousands of others fighting
for their communities around the clock
without pay and with little rest despite
all they have endured they are still
giving back
they won't leave
why
because they're fighting for something
deeper than money prestige or power
they're fighting for their home
when his neighbors didn't know how to
vote during the pandemic maurice
co-founded the philly voter engagement
network he built a team of hundreds of
people working to spread the vote about
mail-in ballot options and polling place
changes
when not enough was done to educate
students about voting tom co-founded pa
youth vote he built a coalition of
teachers in more than 40 schools
to become voter champions and empower
their students to take civic action when
nothing was done about gun violence in
her neighborhood kendra started stand up
nice town she brought a new resource to
her community every week to change the
conversation
like job readiness training and
counseling services
when an outside entity tried to take
over her neighborhood public school
kendra galvanized parents to vote for it
to be kept in the public's control
and it is through community organizing
that she won her seat in city council
still fighting for justice for her home
community organizing
is treated as volunteer work
but
it shouldn't be it's why we have a
five-day work week
it's why we have paid time off
it's why everyone in this room has the
right to vote
we stand here today because community
organizers fought for us
when this country was founded there was
no concept of overtime pay or minimum
wage child labor was not uncommon
but people unionized and fought
organizing major strikes to demand
better
their actions built the momentum for the
fair labor standards act banning
oppressive child labor and instituting
the work week we have today
it's time we stop taking community
organizing for granted and pay it
forward
i believe in people power
i believe that we need more grassroots
leaders who are from the communities
they serve people like tina marie tom
kendra and maurice people who won't give
up because this is their home
community organizing is often treated as
volunteer work like i said but it
shouldn't be
we should really focus on centering
these people in the movement for justice
it's easy to become complacent
to feel like everything is perfect
to do nothing
but i'm asking you for just a few
minutes
to think about where you sit in this
world
even right now here at stamford in this
very room today
take a look around
we are sitting in an institution with a
37 billion dollar endowment
stanford's highest paid employee makes
over 8 million dollars
hugging the western edge of campus is
sandhill road the epicenter of venture
capital and the most expensive street in
all of america
at the same time on el camino real which
hugs the northeastern edge of campus
dozens of rvs are parked
filled with people just trying to get by
abigail couldn't afford the 600 increase
from her landlord in rent so she and her
family of 10 moved into an rv
tanika and ivan moved into an rv when
the city started cracking down on people
living in cars despite both being
employed
they couldn't afford the rent
what may look perfect from your vantage
point
looks like hell to someone who doesn't
have that privilege
we were all raised to believe in the
american
dream but what does the american dream
mean
if we can't all have it
what does it mean when the barriers are
so high
only a few can access it
and what does it mean when we continue
to always leave the same people behind
community organizers are fighting for
affordable housing generational wealth
and voting rights because they know that
not everyone has access to it
living means being a part of the world
you live in
it means taking care of each other
it means standing up for each other
especially when no one else will
that is what the american dream should
look like
and so i'm asking you today
to care to make it better
to advocate for invest in and center the
voices of community organizers like tina
marie tom maurice and kendra
it's not about any one of us
it's about all of us
it's about what makes us human
caring for each other
so let's get to work together
[Applause]
[Music]
you